[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 60,18 bienvenue dans cette
édition du journal du lundi 12 juillet
voici les titres
une prouesse artistique réalisé devant
le public saint quentinois la funambule
tatiana motion mongon gabon gongga à
relier la bibliothèque universitaire à
l'immeuble edison à guyancourt c'était
samedi une performance sur un fil à 20
mètres 200 mètres de traverser au dessus
de la perspective de marta pan reportage
l'été débute une période propice pour
les collectivités afin de réaliser leurs
travaux focus sur le programme dans le
département des yvelines avec mes
invités richard ii le pierre
vice-président mobilité aux transports
aux départements et pierre nougaret
directeur interdépartemental de la
voirie à zoom également sur les
chantiers menés dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
et puis du football à la fin de ce
journal alors que la finale de l'euro
2000 va se jouer hier la coupe des
nations nantaise prenait fin également à
mantes-la-jolie une deuxième édition
remportée par le mali face à l'algérie
devant un public en folie un retour à la
fin de cette édition et semaine de fête
nationale également cette semaine
jusqu'à ce jeudi tv 60,18 vous fait
vivre ce 14 juillet premier numéro ce
soir avec la préparation des défilés
aériens et pédestre dans les yvelines
[Musique]
le président de la république s'exprime
ce soir il prendra la parole à 20 heures
dans une allocution france emmanuel
macron devrait a détaillé les nouvelles
mesures du gouvernement pour contrer
l'émergence est du variant delta du
colis de 19 en france 4256 cas ont été
détectés ce week-end au niveau national
des chiffres qui inquiètent également au
niveau local regarder sur une semaine et
données de contamination sont en hausse
dans les yvelines plus 18,8 pour le taux
d'incidence est le nombre de nouveaux
contaminée pour 100000 habitants le taux
de tests positifs est repassé au-dessus
de 1 % pour le moment
l'augmentation des contaminations ne se
répercute pas à l'hôpital 123 patients
étaient hospitalisés hier dans les
yvelines - 19 en une semaine 22
personnes toujours en réanimation est
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
1850 de personnes sont mortes du colis
de 19 dans les hôpitaux du département
avant de parler de la prestation de la
funambule dont je vous parlais dans les
titres et le dossier de la rédaction
toute cette semaine
tv 60,18 s'intéresse au 14 juillet nous
débutons ce soir avec une immersion dans
les préparatifs de la fête nationale est
dans les yvelines des troupes à pied les
unités aériennes s'entraîne pour le jour
j ai direction sat aurier et la base de
vélizy villacoublay pour découvrir les
coulisses de cette préparation
un reportage de nicolas landry bixente
mayence insisté ban et cory stern chez
nous
ils sont plus de 4400 femmes et hommes à
se préparer au défilé pédestre du
14-juillet différentes unités dépendante
de l'armée de terre de la marine
nationale de l'armée de l'air de la
gendarmerie encore des sapeurs pompiers
pendant quatre jours ils se sont
entraînés à cette véritable opération un
entraînement avec cet objectif dégager
un sentiment particulier chez les
spectateurs
ce qui m'importe si vous voulez c'est
que le défilé dégage un sentiment de
force de puissance et de cohésion
ça se voit au combat mais ça se voit
aussi dans un exercice un peu technique
voilà comme l'ordre serré l'ordre serré
un exercice de base pour un militaire ce
sont les fondamentaux pour tous soldats
aspirants je vois déjà des gens qui
arrivent et qui se sont entraînés
c'est très clair voilà ce qui a
maintenant c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on
mette au point ce sont les réglages
c'est à dire qu'il faut que les blocs
soit compact 1 que les distances entre
les unités soient bien respectées et ça
ça demande de l'entraînement appartenant
à l'unité du sous marin nucléaire
d'attaqué émeraude le quartier-maître
première classe romain va défiler pour
la première fois il vient de terminer
une opération de huit mois mené dans la
région indo pacifique
le défilé une bouffée d'air frais pour
ces marins le premier rond c'était
impressionnant de voir de voir tout ce
monde et il a toujours des petits
réglages à faire mais on est sur la
bonne voie et on sera plus que prêt le
jour j
le défilé pour le 14 juillet sur les
champs-elysées devant le président de la
république c'est un honneur de par notre
mission qu'on vient de terminer ses
ailes à la reconnaissance de la nation à
ses armes et j'en suis très fier dans le
ciel de paris 90 cet appareil
participeront au défilé 2021
hélicoptères avions chasseurs différents
aéronefs de l'armée de l'air de la
marine nationale de la gendarmerie ou
encore de la sécurité civile avec une
organisation particulière le défilé qui
est constitué d'un ensemble de
patrouille qui vont attendre dans
l'ouest parisien
qu'on leur donne le top départ est bien
se rejoignent petit à petit sur un axe
qui est la kz2 défilé et c'est bien par
le respect des altitudes le respect des
vitesses le respect des trajectoires le
respect des horaires
le respect des procédures radio que la
sécurité aérienne est garanti pour son
deuxième défilé du 14 juillet le
commandant nicolas pilotera un mirage
2000d le ravitailleur va ouvrir la voie
en se mettant à leur est en suivant
scrupuleusement une trajectoire etc
après là où j'interviens bon avec
maillet messi au rafale est derrière et
messi 2000d ou et bien à mon initiative
va bien je ferai resserré le dispositif
pour assurer parfaitement l'alignement
et la formation lors du défilé comme
chaque année les alpha jet de la
patrouille de france ouvriront le défilé
suivi des avions des troupes à pied des
hélicoptères et des troupes motorisées
et montées la visite de nadia ce lundi
dans les yvelines la ministre délégué à
la ville s'est rendu aux mureaux ce
matin elle est venue signer la
convention permettant le déploiement des
bataillons de la prévention dans cinq
quartiers prioritaires de la ville est
de douze éducateurs et médiateur ils
seront déployés le long pour mission
d'aller vers les jeunes les plus en
difficulté pour les reconnecter à la
société notamment via la scolarité la
formation et l'emploi l'objectif c'est
de lutter contre la délinquance et la
violence un dispositif à hauteur de 600
mille euros financés par le ministère de
la ville
[Musique]
elle était à un moment aux privilégiés
par les collectivités pour effectuer des
travaux de d'entretien notamment sur la
voirie zoom dans cette édition notamment
sur ce programme et dans le département
des yvelines et on en parle avec mes
deux invités en visioconférence richard
ii le pierre bonsoir il est le maire de
la commune du chéné rocancourt tout
récent vice président du conseil
départemental en charge des mobilité et
des transports est également pierre
nougaret qui est avec 2o bonsoir bon
sens vous êtes vous le directeur
interdépartemental de la voirie pour le
pays
yvin hauts-de-seine l'établissement
public interdépartemental et qui
regroupe depuis 2016 le 78 92 qui sont
dans une stratégie de rapprochement est
d'ailleurs la compétence de la voirie
est une compétence maintenant mutuelle
entre les deux départements c'est bien
ça donc les sont restés propriété des
départements et il ya un établissement
interdépartemental qui assure la
conduite d'opérations sur c'est pour les
travaux de chaussée avec dans le
département qui gère et entretient un
réseau 1 to de 1600 km de réseau routier
c'est important de l'entretenir
peut-être richard ii le pierre de le
moderniser aussi régulièrement de
profiter de période peut-être un peu
plus creuse comme l'était pour et bien
faire ces travaux
alors il est évidemment essentiel quand
on à 1600 km de voies c'est la priorité
c'est évidemment d'entretenir le
patrimoine et donc les trois quarts du
budget est consacré à l'entretien de ces
chaussées après on mène également des
projets d'aménagement matière
d'amélioration de la sécurité routière
ce un sujet sur lequel vos administrés
sont évidemment sensible donc elle sait
apprendre de chantier sont consacrés à
améliorer ses points noirs en matière de
sécurité routière c'est un budget
d'environ 2 à 2,5 millions d'euros qui
sera consacrée cette année sur le sujet
et puis après on porte également du
développement de l'infrastructure de
circulation douce je pense évidemment
aux pistes cyclables qui sont très
attendus par par beaucoup beaucoup nous
administrer et et la rénovation des
ouvrages d'art et je voudrais évidemment
citer de manière emblématique aa
chantier qu'on va mener sur sur presque
trois ans qu'elle à la réhabilitation du
pont entre sartrouville et
maisons-laffitte de cons la 2e db à un
chantier à près de 9 millions d'euros
donc on étale sur
sur quatre exercices pour le réaliser
qui fait aussi partie des missions du
département en matière d'entretien son
patrimoine voirie en reparler tout à
l'heure sur la période les tc on imagine
propice pour mener ce genre de travaux
pour une pas trop on va dire empiéter
sur le quotidien des yvelinois que ça ne
gêne pas trop le quotidien des yvelinois
ya forcément moins de monde peut-être
aussi dans les yvelines était évidemment
évidemment dans notre zone urbaine de dd
zibeline fn dans tout le département
cette période d'été et de vacances les
plus propices à la réalisation de ces
travaux que ce soit dans nos communes où
sont les infra du département
sagen sagen - et donc c'est une période
assez classique on mobilise des équipes
pour rénover notre patrimoine être prêt
à la rentrée il ya des chantiers
qu'évidemment vont perdurer sur une
période plus importante mais la période
estivale et d'une période on a beau moi
non dans le rouge dans nos villes et
donc manger de moins c'est important
aussi et vous avez parlé de ce programme
des chantiers 60 chantiers en tout
d'entretien de modernisation qui vont
concerner les route départementale des
yvelines
ça a été un grand le chantier
emblématique on va en dire un mot sur ce
pont dans un instant entre maisons
laffitte et et sartrouville sur les
types de chantier vous en avez évoqué
quelques uns on va pas à citer les 60
mais les grands types de chantiers que
l'on va pouvoir avoir cet été dans le
département quels sont ils je le redis
c'est essentiellement des des projets
d'entraidé des chantiers d'aménagement
d'entretien de la chaussée ce qui est
important de retenir et vous l'avez sur
la carte des chantiers c'est qu'ils sont
très équitablement répartis sur
l'ensemble du territoire
et ça rappelle la fonction de solidarité
que le département vis-à-vis des
communes qu'elles soient contredites
évidemment toutes les petites communes
n'ont pas les moyens de mener son
patrimoine et ses teintes responsabilité
d'être présent sur l'ensemble du
territoire je pense notamment à la zone
rurale mais puisqu'on va évoquer le
sujet de ce pont ce pont relie deux
communes qui ne sont pas les communes
les plus petits des e-menaces approuvé
des maisons laffitte sont sur le haut de
la pile et pourtant et pourtant cette
l'entretien l'entretien ce pont dépasse
largement les moyens qu'elle pourrait
consacrer donc le département est
solidaire de l'ensemble des communes
petites et grandes mais évidemment avec
une attention toute particulière aux
communes les plus les plus petites
et je pense à celles de l'ouest du
département et vous verrez sur la carte
l'ensemble de nos chantiers sont très
équitablement réparties sur le
territoire c'est un sujet auquel on
attache une importance toute
particulière mais on peut retrouver la
carte sur le site 1 qui s'affiche qui
s'est affichée déjà en bas de l'écran il
va s'afficher
voilà pour le site et retrouvez toutes
les informations pour dire un mot vous
le disiez sur ce chantier emblématique
celui de maisons laffitte et
sartrouville ce pont entre les deux
communes avec un secteur très dense à la
circulation c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
fallait agir alors on a compris que
l'entretien des routes départementales
étaient quelque chose d'important mais
sur un secteur aussi dans ce qui est
empruntée par de nombreux véhicules 28
mille véhicules je crois par jour sur ce
secteur il était important oui de faire
ce gros chantier qui va durer trois ans
à vous en parliez tout à l'heure
oui peut-être comme suède pour apporter
quelques quelques éléments sur la nature
de ce chantier
vous avez des éléments supplémentaires à
nos attentes et nous parle d'art qui a
été construit après la guerre et donc
sur lequel qui arrivait avec un degré
d'usure de certains équipements et vous
venez de rénover de manière lourde et
importante donc les travaux se passe
surtout sur la surface du tablier en
dessous condom qu'on ne voit pas
forcément quand on circule en surface et
on a réduit les conditions de
circulation de manière à corinne pouvoir
laisser passer les voitures mais même
des limitations de largeur des
limitations d'accès pour les pour les
piétons et vélos
l'idée c'est de travailler pour changer
un saint-andré qui pond qui se situe en
sous-face de tabliers et comme on fait
tous assurent qu'ils souhaitent
collation bas c'est non c'est non on ne
peut pas on peut pas couper le pont
parce que vous aimez rivne bien ce qui
se passerait si on peut la circulation
c'est pour ça que ça s'étale sur trois
ans avec une une première phase assez
importante de qui commence à l'été
cet été ce que je peux dire sur ce
sur ce jeu et on arrive déjà à la fin de
cet entretien mais je le répète le site
internet qui s'est affichée pour avoir
la carte de ces chantiers éviter
peut-être les désagréments voir s'il y a
des impacts sur la circulation rester
informés via le site qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran et donc je le disais 1,60
chantier cet été sur les route
départementale des yvelines
on va vous remercier et merci à vous et
à richard de l'eau pierre et merci à
pierre nougarède d'avoir été avec nous
et et d'avoir parlé de ce sujet de
l'entretien de ces travaux d'été des
routes départementales
alors justement après les yvelines place
son curseur sur une agglomération celle
de saint quentin en yvelines plusieurs
chantiers d'été sont déjà en cours
environ 5 km de voirie sont concernés
pour un budget d'un peu plus d'un
million d'euros les détails avec astrid
bergère mélanie poquet et patrick
jacques de dixmude 1,5 km au total neuf
villes de l'agglomération concernés une
partie de la voirie de saint quentin en
yvelines se refait une beauté durant
l'été c'est juste travaux d'aménagement
soit d'entretien des veaux résistante
vous savez un patrimoine important sur
cinquantaine d'amputés juste soin bio
rénové soit de requalifier des voiries
sont un axe important notamment de
rendre la suppression plus plus pacifié
pour les circulations douces
on fait aussi des travaux d'aménagement
de pistes cyclables complémentaires par
exemple 12 opérations sont prévues
l'ensemble des travaux est
majoritairement financée par
l'agglomération et se dérouleront
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août
ce bourreau minimiser les nuisances
ainsi des travaux de voirie bref les
ondes aubry veut dire blocage sans
fermeture de voirie au moins
partiellement notamment sur lorsqu'on a
des travaux donné déviation des réseaux
de bus également puis dit forcément un
peu d'encadrement tout l'intérêt c'est
de faire ça là où le minimum de
nuisances possibles et les gros travaux
continuent aussi comme les aménagements
de la rn10 à trappes
on a travaillé donc historique entre
conséquent dont les travaux vont
accélérer cet été notamment sur la
deuxième quinzaine du mois d'août avec
la démolition de l'ancien pont qu'on
cache l1 qui surplombe la n10 et avec un
combo de provisions qui vient d'être
installé
c'est sans doute dû aux travaux les plus
importants en termes d'impact à venir et
ce avec un budget qui n'est pas que 50
ces travaux de rénovation occasionne des
déviations de bus ou des fermetures de
routes
la copine n'a pas ralenti le calendrier
le
nombre de chantiers n'a pas augmenté
pour cet été 2010 21 le 8 avril dernier
la ville de mantes-la-jolie apprenait
que le val fourré été retenu comme
cartier innovant et écologique par la
région ile-de-france une enveloppe de 4
millions d'euros qui va permettre de
financer des opérations d'aménagement
durable de quatre espaces publics les
détails avec mélanie poké et alex béraud
des rues bientôt revaloriser nungesser
et coli doré et docteur bretonneau font
partie du renouvellement urbain du val
fourré il est labellisé quartier
innovant et écologique par l'île de
france
si nous ne résolvons pas ces quartiers
si nous leur construisons pas à ces
quartiers et bien c'est des êtres
humains qui vont vivre mal qu'ils vont
avoir des conditions de vie se dégrader
ici c'est 22 mille habitants sur ce
quartier qui au fond et plusieurs
quartiers c'est une ville et nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que vingt-deux
mille habitants soit dans une condition
de vie dégradées la signature a eu lieu
vendredi 9 juillet dernier un
financement à hauteur de 4 millions
d'euros le montant maximal possible
trois autres aménagements sont prévus il
concerne les mailles lopez et roussard
et les abords de l'école rouge et bleu
on va avoir des nouvelles promenades à
l'intérieur du val fourré on va créer
des chemins pour qu'on puisse se
déplacer à pied en vélo en trottinette
les gens une demande de mobilité
différentes
et quand on a fait une réunion de
concertation il ya beaucoup de gens qui
nous ont dit mais le quartier du val
fourré ya beaucoup d' espaces verts mais
ils sont pas assez mis en valeur
ce label est un contrat de quatre ans
qui peut être prolongé de deux années
supplémentaires un projet de
renouvellement du quartier du val fourré
plus large à hauteur de 400 millions
d'euros est lancé on reste à mantes la
jolie avec du football dénouement ce
week-end de l'euro 2020 les pilotes
aussi pour la coupe des nations mantaise
ses équipes s'affrontaient depuis un
mois au stade jean paul david la finale
voyait s'opposer ce dimanche le mali au
sénégal
retour sur la compétition qui a encore
attiré les foules sur les images
d'astrid bergère 11 juillet 2021 jour du
sacre de l'italie à l'euro face à
l'angleterre jeu
également deux victoires pour le malien
la coupe des nations mantaise au terme
d'une finale qui a fait le plein au
stade jean paul david mantes-la-jolie
l'équipe s'impose 3 buts à 1 contre
l'algérie la joie des supporters au
rendez-vous grâce à des buts de
coulibaly un doublé de baradji le mali
succède à la république démocratique du
congo au palmarès de la compétition
c'est tellement chose que je ressens que
je peux même pas décrire ce que j'ose
que la victoire que le mali puis 106
mali puissant si un nouveau succès pour
la coupe des nations nantaise qui
revenait pour une deuxième édition à
mantes-la-jolie pendant un mois 16
équipes se sont affrontées pour la
victoire finale de la france au ghana en
passant par le portugal et la tunisie
[Musique]
oh
les ihm sont joués avant le coup d'envoi
les matches se disputent devant une
tribune qui pouvait accueillir jusqu'à
3500 supporters
une grande fête organisée par
l'association jeunesse et diversité
après les nombreux confinement c'est un
moment on se retrouve c'est un moment
qui nous permet de de penser à autre
chose de pouvoir passer des moments
aussi en famille parce qu'il faut il ya
des familles qui sont ici présents et
des enfants
le maire qui est là les autorités donc
c'est une fête pour tout toute la ville
de mantes a joué un moment très apprécié
par les spectateurs mafieuses ça permet
aux jeunes qui restent dans la cité de
s'éclater c'est pas nuire c'est le
mélange des cultures
c'est bien ça nous permet de tous nous
réunir et voilà de permettre aux jeunes
qui vont pas en vacances de profiter un
minimum la coupe des nations mantaise un
événement déjà installé à mantes la
jolie le rendez vous est d'ores et déjà
donné en 2022 pour la troisième édition
mais dans un instant on parle sport dans
le cetud sport présentée par michael lmi
d'eurostat retrouver à partir de 18h30
sur tv 78 plusieurs reportages au
programme et notamment cette soirée mma
sur laquelle michael elle me d'euros
reviendra c'était une compétition d'arts
martiaux mixtes qui était organisée
samedi 10 juillet au sdcl center de
maurepas une dizaine de combats étaient
au programme dans cette soirée retour
sur cet événement avec des images de
patrick jacques de dixmude
une cage de la sueur des coups
spectaculaires le sdcl center de
maurepas organise un gala d'arts
martiaux mixtes ce samedi 10 juillet le
rendez-vous de mma faisait partie du ffa
à ce challenge nous ici on ouverte
innovants et ça fait passer notre coeur
de métier donc pouvoir combattre pourra
revoir les gars qui sont entraînés dur
toute l'année pour aller s'exprimer avec
d'autres personnes en france c'est
génial au programme dix combats
professionnels de la catégorie des moins
de 57 kg au moins 220 kg dont deux
combats féminins
parmi les participants un local qui
s'entraînent dans cette salle de
maurepas
il ya un bon niveau il ya beaucoup de
jeunes combattants qui débute et
niveau ce soir 22 élevé je pense pour
permettre au plus grand nombre de voir
les combats le rendez-vous à huit clos
était retransmis en direct sur une
plateforme de streaming
il faut que ça soit du live parce que
comme pour l'instant on évite les
regroupements d'euros de personnes de
pouvoir l'élargir et tout le monde
puisse le voir en même temps qu'on le
fait pas c'est génial on n'a pas
l'impression d'être des dettes des
dettes encore à hugo quand on est malgré
tout on a tout le monde qui peut suivre
les internautes ont notamment pu voir le
club de maurepas brille également dans
la cage avec la victoire de l'illinois
maxime flop si oui où deuxième round par
ko ca attendu le bon timing et j'ai
senti le coup et après je vais donner
comme on citera fait mouche
donc voilà je suis très content
aujourd'hui mais j'ai encore beaucoup de
travail à notre combat devrait être
organisée en octobre dans les yvelines
avec du public cette fois ci si les
conditions sanitaires le permettent
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal le
sujet dont je vous parlais en début de
journal avec cette prouesse artistique
je vous disais réalisé par une funambule
dans le ciel saint quentinois celle de
tatiana mossot gongga qui a relié la
bibliothèque universitaire à deux
grilles en cours à l'immeuble edison qui
est toujours invaincu en cours on vous
en parlait et bien dans les titres de ce
journal on ne va pas pouvoir vous
proposer ce reportage ce soir en raison
d'un problème technique il sera bien sûr
à retrouver dans une prochaine édition
du journal sur tv 78 très belle soirée à
tous
[Musique]